you want to be connected all the time
this is where societies headed this is
where the cool people are this is where
the knowledge is this is where all the
forward-thinking people are and that in
fact has been true for the last 15 or 20
years that's the direction we've all
been moving in i call it digital
maximalism in my book the more connected
you are the better I think it's finally
dawning on people that that really
deserves a second look that it's not
taking us to the place as thinkers as as
friends and parents and children and
teachers all the roles we play in our
lives that use of digital technology
nonstop around the clock isn't serving
our highest purposes is becoming clear
to to most thoughtful people so the
question is just raising your own
consciousness and then stepping back
from it and thinking is that am I going
about this the best way this always
happens I'm returning to my historical
theme now but it always happens in the
early stages of Technology you know the
telephone in the early days of marketing
the telephone particularly in Europe it
was marketed as a one-way listening
device for listening to the Opera no
idea that it might be used for a two-way
as a two-way conversation device which
actually turned out to be the best use
of it but it hadn't occurred to people
I think there are
a lot of tech solutions ways in which
the technologies will evolve to help us
I think the ones that we have in place
today are that are available are not the
best you know they're very primitive you
know this idea that a filter can
actually go through your email and
pre-op prioritize what you should see
now and what you should see later and so
forth it they're really really crude and
I think people who've tried them people
i know just anecdotally have largely
abandoned them but i think we are moving
in a direction where the machines are
going to become that they're always
becoming more intelligent let's face it
you know they're going to evolve in a
direction where they help us but at the
same time we can't just rely on the
machines to do the rethinking of the
technology for us because after all
these are the technologies that were
concerned about and they don't have
brains as strong as ours it's up to us
to figure out how to design them for our
lifestyle of where we want to take
ourselves so I think it the most
important task we have now and this is
really what I argue in Hamlet's
blackberry is to change our own thinking
about the devices so we recognize that
we need balance to get the most out of
them and that once we have that balance
the device is fixing themselves will
actually become less urgent because we
will have done the primary work of
repairing our own consciousness about
the devices
yeah there's there's so many practical
steps that it's almost impossible to
list them all in fact in touring around
talking about my book since it came out
a few months ago everywhere I go I hear
about somebody who has some new twist on
how to disconnect so you know in the
book I talked quite extensively about
rituals that people can develop in the
office for example where some
forward-thinking companies have tried
you know certain days of the week
without email certain hours of the day
quiet time for employees away from
screens this is happening at colleges
and universities those rituals are very
useful but there are also all kinds of
tailor-made interesting things that
people are trying i'll tell you one that
sort of humorous that came up in a radio
call-in show i was on a radio public
radio show talking about my book and
somebody called in and said a friend of
his it wasn't the caller but a friend
when he goes away he gives on vacation
and he knows he's going to have a hard
time disconnecting the day he goes away
he gives all of his passwords and
usernames to various friends so one
friend will get the twitter password
username another friend will get
facebook and other friend will get the
email and on the day he leaves they're
all under instructions to go in and
change the username and password so he
has no access even if he wanted if he
tried to sign on when he's away he can't
and when he comes back they give him the
new passwords so is these hilarious sort
of creative spins on disconnecting that
people are trying because they see how
addicted they are and I think it's
wonderful I think it's going to be
different for everybody the methods I
talked about in the book that I've tried
and that people I know tried companies
that I've studied have tried are not
going to be for everyone you know I
think we're all different we all have
different needs we all have different
tolerances I don't pretend to tell other
families that they should disconnect on
the weekends the way we do there are
some parents who work on the weekends
you know which it just happens to work
for us